et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre jeantet remaniant radiologue
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes bonsoir jean
pierre interne amiens merci d'être avec
nous à vos côté florian philippot
président des patriotes bonsoir florian
philippon merci d'être avec nous alors
ce premier feu vert en des députés une
bonne nouvelle plus tôt pour vous ou
jean-pierre tard gagnant je pense que
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais je
voudrais simplement replacer le débat
est ce qu'il ya un seul français qui
s'est pas fait vacciner on va dire
contre le dtpolio il ya onze vaccins
obligatoires en france
si la santé a fait des progrès dans
point de vue population c'est pas
tellement accru de très humble c'est pas
grave on va dire ou au traitement mais
c'est essentiellement via deux cause
l'hygiène et la deuxième cause c'est la
vaccination à partir de là on a jubilé
le choléra on a jugulé la polio mais
dites moi je suis d'une génération je
suis plus âgé ou j'avais des copains qui
avait des séquelles de police on en voit
plus maintenant et en temps de paix de
ça j'en vois quasiment plus ou aux joies
des gens qui sortent de ma génération la
variole a été éradiquée donc le débat de
dire que l'on crée une discrimination
entre ceux qui sont vaccinées ou pas je
dirais ça ne pose aucun problème vous ne
pouvez pas vous inscrire dans la
fonction publique hospitalière
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné contre
l'hépatite b c'est la loi
vous ne pouvez pas aller en guyane si
vous n'avez pas un certificat de fièvre
jour de vaccination
florian philippot vous je sais que vous
n'êtes pas des mêmes avis on arrive à ce
que vous redoutiez mais c'est vrai que
le docteur terme à nyon vient d'apporter
quand même des éléments assez implacable
vous êtes d'accord un petit peu ou pas
du tout non mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord si vous voulez choses l'une
soit le vaccin que les 19 et obligatoire
il fallait dire il fallait pas dire
linverse et macron fin novembre a dit
d'anvers justement précisé c'était la
liberté vaccinale et s'il n'est pas
obligatoire alors on ne peut pas mettre
en place un outil qui bon moi aussi j'ai
fait le fiel rejoint parce que je suis
en guyane
on va pas en guyane où dans 20 pays
africains où ils seraient également
demandées
tous les quatre matins en revanche les
éléments qui sont concernés par ce pass
sanitaire c'est un précédent c'est une
première c'est pour aujourd'hui aller
dans un rassemblement de plus de 1000
personnes
ce sera des festivals je serais allé au
stade ça sera un meeting politique ce
sera un une fois une exposition et puis
hier cédric au secrétaire d'état au
numérique a dit pas ça sera aussi dans
les salles de cinéma qui ont plus de
1000 spectateurs
il a précisé ce sera aussi dans les
restaurants n'ont plus de mille couverts
et on voit bien que on ouvre une boîte
de pandore ou en fait on crée selon
l'état de santé de florian philippot
qu'est ce qui nous dérange le plus parce
que vous dites nous dit voilà dans ce
cas il fallait rendre obligatoire la
vaccination des débuts c'est
l'hypocrisie ou finalement c'est la
discrimination que cela entraînerait
selon vos bas c'est très hypocrite parce
que c'est une manière de rendre
obligatoire sans le dire et deuxièmement
et moi je suis contre l'obligation
vaccinale je précise je suis pour la
liberté vaccinale et deuxièmement c'est
un précédent tir ils ont créé une
ségrégation sanitaire selon le son
statut sérologique
selon son choix thérapeutiques selon son
choix de vaccination on met le doigt
dans un engrenage extrêmement dangereux
parce que demain une fois qu'on aura
installé ces outils les qr codes
l'application numérique et de ça qui
nous dit qu'on va pas y ajouter d'autres
vaccins d'autres choix thérapeutiques
d'autres pathologies qui seront
discriminante pour avoir le droit
d'aller dans telle ou telle lieux ou de
pratiquer telle ou telle activité ou de
pouvoir avoir une telle ou telle prêts
bancaires ou travail ça on entre on
ouvre une boîte de pandore ont créé en
dehors de tout débat éthique et moral
quand je crois que c'est un vrai
problème moral éthique cette affaire on
crée un précédent qui va nous amener
probablement quelque chose d extrêmement
inquiétant est d'ailleurs plusieurs pays
ne s'y sont pas trompés et ils ont
interdit le passeport qualités à
commencer par les états unis
pierre-jean tamagnan quand vous entendez
ces arguments vous y êtes sensibles et
moi je suis obligé de constater que
cette pandémie tue encore 300 personnes
par jour en france que nos systèmes de
ranimation sont en légère décrue mais en
restant saturation et on a alors
jetterait croyable
de la chance d'avoir un vire variant
anglais en france parce que si on avait
demain le parisien brésilien ou
sud-africain
las il ne panique totale donc je crois
que si on veut on va dire rendre une
liberté aux gens de se déplacer d'aller
voir leur famille d'aller voir les
restaurants ça passe par un certain
nombre de contraintes je crois qu'il
faut je dirai tout le monde est bien
d'accord peut-être que le pass de
vaccination c'est pas forcément le bon
terme je défends moi un carnet de
vaccination électronique pour chaque
prescient soit citoyen et responsable
des zags et puis quand on est tous dans
la rue devant un bus rouge
on respecte leur on peut être content ou
les limitations de vitesse que l'on veut
mais dans tous les cas quelqu'un de
sensé pas s'arrêter au feu rouge
donc la possibilité d'avoir un qr code
alors avec des limites c'est à dire que
si jamais vous avez effectivement
quelqu'un qui est enregistrée il faut
qu'à la fin de cet événement ça s'efface
ces données mais c'est le meilleur moyen
pour protéger la population
c'est indispensable si on veut revenir
on a tous marre les soignants en
particulier parce qu'on voit la mort et
on ne sait pas forcément toujours bien
l'accepter parce que quand ça devient
répétitif
rappelez-vous au début de la première
pandémie
c'était on va dire un égrenage de nombre
de gens maintenant ça n'émeut personne
vous voyez des scènes en a dont on brûle
mais des milliers de personnes
il ya plus d'oxygène en ainsi demain ça
nous arrive alors il ya un autre
problème si vous voulez c'est que ce
passeport vaccinale va nous permettre on
va dire d'avoir ce carnet de vaccination
électronique que je souhaite ardemment
c'est que ça nous permet de savoir
je dirais chaque personne c'est qu'elle
à 7,25 on peut donc être libre après
d'aller parce que le risque de
contaminer est faible et on a un autre
souci c'est le défaut qu'on peut
rencontrer proment sur la vaccination
avec les vaccins à adénovirus ou le
danemark par exemple s'opposent
astrazeneca s'oppose à johnson and
johnson
or la campagne vaccinale française
repose à presque 30 2 33% sur ces deux
vaccins
donc il ya un risque on va tarder à
vacciner la population
il ya toujours des gens il faut
respecter le libre à vis des gens qui
seront contents n'y peut rien par contre
on leur demande de effectivement de
faire en sorte de ne pas contaminer les
autres
ce que quand on voit les scènes dans la
rue sans masque ça laisse un peu raide
en tout cas les français sont plutôt
court à regarder ce sondage harris
interactive - lci l'instauration de cet
outil pour accéder donc à ces grands
événements recueille le soutien quand
même 67% de la population
alors ce n'est qu'un sondage mais
florian philippot vous êtes étonné parce
que c'est vrai qu'on parlait bien il ya
quelques mois de ce scepticisme très
français c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'on n'a
plus le choix et que les français
veulent avant tout retrouver une vie
normale vous comprenez justement ce
sondage
non mais je suis inquiet parce qu'un
chantage de la peur évident si vous
voulez on a fait croire aux gens ça sont
si vous voulez retrouver leur liberté
c'était au bout de la seringue ou
c'était au bout du test pcr et en fait
on fait de la liberté devrait être un
absolu ce qui est dans notre devise
d'ailleurs un au fronton de nos mairies
et c'est même le premier mot on en fait
une variable d'ajustement sanitaire en
jouant sur la peur menée par ayant
décidé le variant sud africain bien s'il
vous arrive ça va être terrible
je finirai qu'il a représenté un moment
60% des contaminations en modèle
département que je connais bien j'y suis
élu on nous a dit ça va être la
catastrophe absolue
il a régressé n'a pas eu le confinement
particulier en modèle ça il a réglé ses
et il n'y a pas eu la catastrophe ou
d'annoncés donc si vous voulez donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de
pousser les gens vers ce truc est pour
moi gravissime c'est une société qui
bascule une civilisation qui bascule où
on pourra donner des droits
supplémentaires aux gens selon leur état
de santé selon leur choix thérapeutiques
et je suis désolé ça n'est pas
compatible avec le l'idée que je me fais
de l'homme de la dignité et de nos
valeurs les plus sacrées et et
deuxièmement il ya des contre-exemples
magic mouse trop puisque les styles y
ont refusé ont interdit ce menace
sanitaire au nom du secret médical qui
doit être respectée or là il sera
bafouée au nom des grandes libertés
il est même en floride pénalisé par une
amende de 5000 dollars si jamais il
était mise en place et je signale que
début mars le texas mississippi où
d'autres états américains ont tous
rouvert ont dit on arrête même le masque
obligatoire à extérieur etc et bart
hayden et d'autre certains médecins leur
promettait l'apocalypse aujourd'hui vous
regardez les classements effondre est il
ya pas du tout eu
contraire l'apocalypse annoncée donc
envie de dire aux français arrêtez de
vous faire avoir par ce discours de
chantage il va vous mener aujourd'hui on
vous dit les événements de plus de 1000
personnes
il ya trois semaines alizé plus de 5000
1 et 2 1 ou voulu dire à n'importe quel
restaurant ou n'importe quel cinéma
c'est une évidence
la mécanique de cette affaire est
toujours la même d'autant qu'en france
nous avons la malchance d'avoir l'union
européenne qui poussent derrière
depuis longtemps en réalité parce que ce
projet dans les cartons seront offerts
depuis longtemps et les que nous sommes
extrêmement soumis à cela nous signale
qu'en suisse il y aura un référendum de
13 juin sur la loi qu'ovide un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
notamment satwa commis de contient le
pass talitha ou pas et ce sera aux
suisses de décider j'aimerais que les
français eux aussi décidé justement vous
parlez de l'union européenne je vous
invite tous les deux à rester avec moi
parce qu'on va aller voir ce qui se
passe en allemagne puisque l'allemagne
et a soumis justement les règles pour
les personnes vaccinées elle a décidé de
lever les restrictions de circulation
pour ceux qui ont été immunisés soit
parce qu'ils sont vaccinés soit parce
qu'elles ont déjà eu que 8 19 cette
décision sera entérinée avant vendredi
par les deux chambres est applicable à
partir de samedi pour en parler avant de
retrouver nos invités nous retrouvons
peter oliver correspondant d'ayrté à
berlin bonsoir peter oliver merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
l'allemagne qui assouplit ses règles
mais on les sent tout de même
restaurants et hôtels fermés faut pas
non plus présenté comment est accueillie
cette décision outre-rhin ce que ça
suscite des débats comme on les entend a
avec nos deux invités au sein des
différentes régions par exemple
yes man cela dépend d'où l'on se trouve
en allemagne six vaudois vont peut-être
renforcer les restrictions vont être à
soutenir si vous avez déjà été vaccinées
si vous pouvez prouver que vous avez des
anticorps contre lacko bild c'est une
très bonne nouvelle si vous habitez dans
les états allemands commencent en barbe
est telle que le brandebourg brême etc
car ils ont déclaré tout comme la
bavière qu'il souhaité assouplir les
restrictions pour les personnes déjà
vaccinées
la ministre de la justice allemand a
déclaré que ces personnes ne faisait qu
à risque au minimum à 2 contracté cette
maladie
et puis s'agirait donc s'il n'est pas
d'assouplissement de violer leurs droits
constitutionnels
certains états ne souhaite pas assouplir
les règles
c'est un débat un coup on ne sait pas si
le bundestag va adopter la mesure
et comme vous l'avez dit c'est un
changement pourrait entrer en vigueur
des recettes mais en tout cas d'ici à la
fin du mois le 27
la raison de cet assouplissement est une
question de chiffres les chiffres
baissent jeu taux de contamination
diminue c'est à dire dont trois aux
mains de personnes contractent lakovic
et le
nombre de lits occupés dans les unités
de soins intensifs sont également en
baisse le seul chiffre qui augmente
c'est le nombre de factions et en
allemagne
huit cent mille personnes ont reçu doses
de vaccin la première dose de vaccin
cours des 24 dernières heures plus de
cent cinquante mille personnes reçues
leur seconde ans au cours des 24
dernières heures 9 % de la population a
reçu un vaccin complet c'est un club
encore très fermé dont les effectifs
augmentent et voilà pourquoi les
législateurs pense qu'on peut assouplir
les restrictions pour les personnes qui
ont été déjà été vaccinées peter la bce
ont pris cette semaine donne aussi aux
vacciner le droit de se réunir plus
nombreux en famille est ce que ce n'est
pas discriminant socialement comment est
accueillie aussi cette mesure dans le
pays ils ont un droit finalement pour
faire la fête
les aspects de cette position c'est
qu'il s'agirait 2 mettre un terme aux
restrictions tout contact donc si vous
avez été vaccinées ainsi que vos amis
vous pouvez vous rassemblez quel que
soit votre ombre est effectivement faire
la fête également être levé par exemple
peuvent savourer les visites chez le
coiffeur ou dans certaines pratiques non
essentiels qui avait été fermé si vous
avez été vaccinées
oui un pass liberté en quelque sorte et
la ministre de la justice a dit qu'il
serait potentiellement non
constitutionnels d'empêcher ces
personnes présentes à ce que minimum de
vivre leur vie habituel beaucoup
d'autres gens prennent la parole et 10
ouvrir le pays pour certaines personnes
vaccinées serait anticonstitutionnelle a
car cela irait à l'encontre du droit un
traitement égal donc il y à vraiment à
ce débat sur le bien fondé
où est la justice de cette décision est
en tout cas bottes les trouvera que vous
obtiendrez défend 222 visent à lutter
ceux qui n'ont pas reçu la vaccination
en tout cas le confinement devrait
courir jusqu'à la fin du mois au moins
et pourrait même continuer en juin
pourrait y avoir alors une réouverture
spontanée et rapide pour les personnes
vaccinées
merci peter oliver correspondant d'ayrté
à berlin et on va retrouver nos deux
invités un pierre jeantet rhin amiens et
florian philippot sur l'opportunité de
se passer ni terre ou non jean-pierre
tamagnan évidemment en tant que médecin
vous le dit c'est très bien mais n'est
ce pas un petit peu injuste quand même
de priver les gens finalement de leur
liberté à partir du moment où tout le
monde en france na n'est pas en mesure
de pouvoir se faire vacciner aujourd'hui
parce qu'il ya une pénurie de vaccins
je pense qu'il faut peut-être pas
forcément poser la question comme ça
pour préciser bien les situations en
moselle c'est 35% de viry sud africain
ce qui a obligé la haute autorité de
santé a changé la stratégie la stratégie
vaccinale
non ça n'est jamais monté à 30 60 %
c'est resté à 35 37 % maximum
vous verrez les chiffres non mais j'ai
les chiffres soul mais je vous rassure
et c'est pour ça qu'ils ont changé la
vaccination ils sont basculées sur
modern art c'est le seul stratégique qui
on peut mettre pour éteindre un incendie
de manière à avoir un arn messagers
vaccin de nom mais parce que je dirais
on a réagi en mettant un vaccin qui est
beaucoup plus efficace alors
qu'astrazeneca
on n'aura pas le sujet et si aux états
unis ça je dirais bien marché c'est
parce que ils ont de la chance les
américains c'est que contrairement à la
france où ça a été un peu laborieux leur
politique vaccinale cancon et puis dire
ils ont beaucoup plus de personnes
vaccinées ce qui permet on va dire
d'obtenir une efficacité alors sur la
perte de chance ou sur la discrimination
je crois que faut pas le voir dans cet
angle là je crois qu'il faut offrir à
tous les français possible je dirais y
compris en déplaçant des cars est ce que
l'on fait dans notre région de manière à
pouvoir vacciner les gens si vous voulez
le plus rapidement après il y aura
toujours des gens qui sont contre et ça
vous pouvez en est en démocratie il faut
respecter mais je pense que la seule
solution on va dire c'est vraiment
d'avoir une vaccination est de permettre
aux gens à partir du monstre ou vacciner
qu'on se retrouve pas avec le fait qu'on
garde des mesures alors sur le sur ce
qu'ils appellent un pass moi qui n'est
pas le bon terme mais je préférerais un
carnet qui permettrait d'avoir des
réelles données perso sur son téléphone
et que l'on peut disposer quand on va
voir son médecin ou service des urgences
il ya une chose qui à mon avis moi me
pose un problème c'est mettre dans le
même sac
si vous voulez la vaccination qui est
l'efficacité 2 le fait des tests le test
pcr même de 72 heures je dirais que
c'est bien mais pendant 72 heures vous
pouvez vous être contaminé donc le seul
facteur de juge il y en a deux c'est le
masque que l'on doit porter en
permanence et la vaccination
et ça ça va nous permettre de revivre et
d'avoir une vie sociale
quand on est en société c'est pas
l'adéquation de liberté individuelle
on doit faire un choix et c'est vrai que
tout le monde respecte la circulation et
que le flou rouge
tous les enfants sont vaccinés c'est
comme ça je veux dire si weir sauver on
va dire une population ne vous avais pas
le choix que florian philippot vous
faire inviter vos dons mais c'est une
vraie question c'est finalement on
laisse de côté l'individualité pour le
collectif parce que l'art pour le coup
ya une question de santé publique majeur
à bakel vie vous nous promettez et
antivirus
malheureusement non à vous messieurs
vous nous avez montré un masque
d'ailleurs un sacré masse qui vous nous
dites que vacciner tous sous couvert
code
tous souhaitent passer ses vents calmes
jeudi en voulant lancer plus une vie
par ailleurs sur le texas d'une trompe
l'oeil quand ils ont ouvert
une 9% de double vacciner et un abus il
y en avait 23 % donc c'est pas le
facteur explicatif simplement les gens
de la place
c'est le premier état quasiment dans la
taille ils sont pas très serré au texas
arrivages en salle alors voilà ce
mois-là en corée du sud où il ya une
densité gigantesque on aurait dû avoir
énormément de morts ils en ont beaucoup
moins que la france donc votre argument
parce qu'ils ont encore et je suis un
geek au vide
ils ont bien sûr parce qu'ils ont tracé
les gens avec un système très
particulier permettait de remonter
toujours une bonne excuse
vous avez toujours une lexus déjà vous
dire monsieur quand on a quand on a
prêté le serment d'hippocrate comme vous
avez dû le faire et qu'on accepte le
différencier les gens selon leur état de
santé leur donner des lois ou pas si si
ou leur choix avec nous ou leur choix
thérapeutiques qu'on accepte cet
engrenage pour de sombres raisons qui
m'échappent mais on creusera la terre
parce que des histoires de pognon
gigantesque derrière cette affaire là
évidemment et le conflit d'intérêts et
je lui posais cette affaire alors je me
dis qu'on n'est plus digne du serment
d'hippocrate
voilà moi je dis aux français ne
rentrait pas dans cette logique ne
mettez pas votre liberté en qr code ne
l'accepté pas c'est fou qui veulent vous
imposer une vie sous masque ou vaccins
ce qr code sous plexiglas etc
lisez le rapport du défenseur des droits
est sorti hier son la manière dont tu
m'a traité pour les raisons que vous
évoquez nos anciens on les a traités
comme des chiens
on les a laissé crever parce qu'il y
avait des médecins plateaux télé qui
disait qu il faut les éloigner faut les
laisser seuls dans leur champ des stars
on les a laissé crever comme une
civilisation n'aurais jamais dû le faire
et même mourir seul sans voir leurs
proches
n'acceptez pas ça fait pression pour que
était enfin il autorise les traitements
une laisse les médecins de prescrire
fait pression et fait pression par
l'outil qu'ils avaient de consommateurs
boycottez dans les enseignes et et les
événements qui demanderont le passé
l'état vous y perdre 10% leur chiffre
d'affaires alors eux mêmes sur notre
fleuron pour tout le gouvernement et on
gagnera
merci à tous les deux et est évidemment
ces propos n'engagent que vous florian
philippot bien évidemment promeut pas le
non port de masques
si en tout cas tous les avis sont
entendus sur rt france merci pierre jean
à magnan et merci à